bonjour à tous bienvenue à bruxelles on
est ensemble pour 30 minutes d'actualité
européenne émission spéciale cette
semaine qu'avons nous fait de nos
démocraties en europe peut-on imaginer
un renouveau un nouveau souffle
souvenez vous il y a cinq ans en pleine
crise économique des milliers
d'espagnols investissent les places dont
la célèbre puerta del sol à madrid
ces indignados créeront un parti podemos
un parti qui célèbre cette semaine un an
de pouvoir à la tête des municipalités
de madrid et de barcelone
depuis il y a eu six risa en grèce le
mouvement cinq étoiles de beppe grillo
en italie et peut-être nuit debout en
france qui sait on en parle avec mes
invités mais d'abord jérôme bonnard nous
emmène place de la république où il a
posé sa caméra quelques jours durant à
l'écouté des assemblées populaires de
nuit debout
depuis le 31 mars chaque soir c'est le
même rituel immuable l'a si bien nommée
place de la république devient une agora
où le temps s'arrête et le débat reprend
françois à 28 ans il est professeur des
écoles c'est merci patron le
documentaire de françois ruffin un des
initiateurs du mouvement qui a éveillé
sa conscience politique et l'a poussée à
investir cette place c'est intéressant
de se dire voilà il ya un an finalement
c'était intéressant c'est d'être
solidaires dans ces luttes l'un est
d'avancer ensemble pour transformer
notre société et en faire une société un
peu moins égoïste enfin une société où
on agit solidairement pour les autres
ici on vote chaque jour des propositions
élaborées en commission féminisme
éducation françafrique antispécistes
mais l'objectif reste la loi travail
l'objet central c'est la convergence des
luttes
le premier objet à atteindre le premier
stade c'est la destruction de l ol
kainry est totale pour le retrait donc
on construit des moyens et le mouvement
il va être fait pour durer et pour
porter une parole qui soit vraiment
démocratique est nourrie d'une
expérience démocratique parce que ça
c'est nouveau c'est à dire que c'est
l'expérimentation sur place des
conditions démocratiques et de débats
qui donne aux gens une nouvelle
conscience politique et le sentiment
justement que des choses sont possibles
recréer de la démocratie pour ouvrir le
champ des possibles à l'image des
voisins indignés espagnols le mouvement
nuit debout cherche avant tout à se
réapproprier le politique la place c'est
un espace aux osrd et d'apprentissage et
d'apprentissage ou des redécouvertes de
la démocratie c'est comme un espagne en
2011 quand le monde ordinaire au lieu il
avait passé dans le gouvernement il n'a
remarqué qu'elle applique la politique
du parti socialiste la droite
des citoyens et citoyennes qui ont
décidé alors prendre le prendre à partie
à main et ses maîtres eux mêmes a
discuté il ya construire des nouveaux de
nouvel horizon politique
rendre la démocratie en main et
construire un nouvel horizon politique
vaste programme
alors comment analyser ce mouvement nuit
debout et ceci peut-il à terme créer
peut-être à l'image de podemos un parti
politique j'en discute avec mes invités
hayder guardian à bâle rubiales bonjour
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne
membre du groupe socialiste et démocrate
et vous êtes espagnol oui un venu à vous
en face de vous
guillaume balas vous êtes élu ici au
sein de ce parlement également au sein
du groupe socialiste et démocrate
bienvenue pour qu'on ait un côté panse
et vous êtes exactement à côté par en
face et vous êtes français bien entendu
dominique riquet député européen
également vous êtes membre du groupe
libéral démocrate
dominique riquet première question
comment est ce que vous aviez vous
analysez en fait cette ce mouvement nuit
debout qui s depuis le 31 mars sur la
place de la république est ce que pour
vous c'est un feu de paille ou ça veut
dire quelque chose je pense que on a
observé ce type de mouvement depuis la
révolution française à intervalles
réguliers avec des organisations
culturelles qui dépendent du moment
difficile de savoir si ça va durer
déboucher sur une structuration etc
c'est une des formes de la démocratie
voilà la démocratie elle est vivante
elle a beaucoup de formes différentes
elle finit en général dans les régimes
démocratiques par s'organiser dans une
démocratie qui représente ça vous choque
pas qu'on occupe des places comme ça
tous les soirs
moi ce qui me choque pas si la
démocratie peut s'exprimer le toutes les
façons la condition qu'elle ne trouble
n'est pas la paix civile
vous êtes d'accord guillaume balas c'est
une forme d'engagement démocratique
classique que ce qui va faire partout et
pas simplement en france pour le
meilleur jeu mais évidemment lui debout
là dedans mais pour le pire ce qu'on a
vu en autriche avec le vote c'est la
recherche de la souveraineté est un pur
et clair c'est le vote
de l'hexagone désormais donc exactement
je pense que partout il y à la recherche
de la souveraineté c'est-à-dire comment
aujourd'hui les peuples peuvent
reprendre leur destin en mains face
notamment ce qui paraît une dilution du
pouvoir politique une incapacité du
politique et des représentants à agir a
expliqué et donc par tous à la dilution
est pas de verticalité pour vous je
pense que la dilution elle se fait dans
une nouvelle verticalité c'est à dire
que les gaffes à google et compagnie les
grandes multinationales traditionnel
détiennent aujourd'hui de plus en plus
de pouvoir économique technologique et
donc de pouvoir politique y compris ils
mettent à la gendarme fait du monde
entier
un certain nombre de nouvelles
stratégies de nouveaux produits a lancé
et de nouveaux contrôles de ce que sont
nos vies et donc je pense volonté de
contrôle démocratique a retrouvé
exactement je pense que sa commande nuit
debout comme d'autres choses sont le
signe de sa et donc il faut que nous les
représentants et bien nous nous trouvons
des solutions nouvelles si nous voulons
pas que ça explose je veux vraiment
comment vous le percevez comment vous
l'analysez aidé à garder la balle depuis
l'espagne vous qui avez connu en fait
ces mouvements en fait d' indignés
pendant quelques mois notamment à madrid
à la postérité
oui c'est vrai que ce qui était en train
d'arriver en france ce qui s'est passé
il ya quelques uns en espagne je pense
qu'il faut voir toujours le côté positif
enfin il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui se
sentent dit il faut qu'on reprenne la
démocratie quand il faut qu'on participe
en politique
et ça c'est très bien parce que dans les
derniers temps en espagne mais je pense
qu'un peu partout les gens ils avaient
regardé la politique d'un autre côté il
ne s'impliquaient plus il ne
s'impliquaient plus du tout et nous
aussi du côté de la politique on se
sentait un peu seul il faut qu'on prenne
des décisions mais on veut avoir les
gens avec nous on veut discuter avec les
gens vont pouvoir prendre des décisions
en commun mais je veux retourner une
chose que d un guillaume je trouve que
c'est très important ce n'est pas
seulement qu'il ya une verticalité de la
politique ce n'est pas que les gens se
sont vus dépourvu c'est que même la
politique à un moment donné elle s'est
vu impuissante à agir et c'est ça ce que
les gens ils ont regardé et se sentent
il faut qu'on prenne encore le pouvoir
et il faut qu on puisse changer les
choses et là je pense qu'il faut qu'on
tire de l'eau essentielle dans la date
du côté de la politique
mais quand on voit dominique riquet par
exemple à quel point la situation paraît
bloquée en france on voit les
raffineries bloquées les centrales
nucléaires qui se sont engagés également
en fait dans le mouvement là sncf la
ratp qui appellent à une grève illimitée
à partir du 2 juin
il ya une volonté en fait de débat
public il ya une volonté typique en fait
de mettre sur la table ces questions
sociales sociétales de lois du travail
etc
où est le blocage selon vous au niveau
social en france est ce que c'est de la
part des syndicats ce que c'est de la
part du gouvernement
ou est-ce que ça bloque on observe
quelque chose qui est paru d'habituel
est moins fréquent qui est un blocage
gauche gauche si spider man et dont on a
pu connaître ça effectivement 2011 sur
la loi contre les retraites de françois
fillon
voilà donc il sort de lait pur classique
mais il est d'autant plus rude
il est d'autant plus rude que il
s'exerce si je puis dire dans la même
direction
là c'est compliqué mais il ya beaucoup
de choses à la fois une contestation de
la loi
dans le fond la démocratie
représentative elle fonctionne comme ça
avec des corps intermédiaires
donc c'est pas une logique qui a aussi
probablement un peu plus que ça il ya un
problème peut-être un peu plus
personnalisé un peu plus humanisé si je
puis dire à entrer sur la personnalité
manuel valls et peut-être aussi du
secrétaire général de l elysée dément
donc et puis il y à aussi là à chocs
culturels sur les bêtas d'entre
guillemets avec d'un côté usages du 49-3
banquier a dû sage des linges conteste
pas ça
et de l'autre côté lusage de la grève
bon alors il ya un conflit là qui est un
conflit à la fois je pense idéologique
mais à mon avis un conflit de pouvoir et
dire comment est ce que vous le percevez
vous depuis l'espagne cette incapacité
qu'on a en france a discuté finalement
bon ça nous est arrivé aussi sait rien
de nouveau mais je pense que il faut
faire un effort de tous les côtés il
faut se mettre dans une tablette
travailler parce que c'est clair que
sinon le blocage ça n'aboutit à rien
juste au blocage de sites de l'europe va
au fait je suis pas spécialiste quand
ces camps mais je ne crois pas je pense
que dans cette descente un certain
moment il ya toujours un certain blocage
ya
un rapport de force ce qui se fait mais
il faut trouver toujours une solution il
faut se mettre à table il faut
travailler
mais comment on réinvente justement
cette solution guillaume balas commun
alors déjà de pas faire les quatre
fautes qui ont été commises
la première c'est ne pas dire que
c'était une recommandation européenne la
question de changer les charges et le
marché du travail le marché du travail
en france et que c'était quelque chose
qui était demandé depuis longtemps et
que comme il ya toujours des débats sur
le budget de la france est bien
évidemment le gouvernement français a
trouvé que c'était une bonne solution
pour montrer à bruxelles que nous étions
complaisant entre guillemets et on ne le
dit pas c'est à la limite ça pourrait
assumer mais ça ne se dit pas donc là
déjà il ya un trouble qui est clair
c'est qu'en fait pour vous ce qui n'a
pas été dit c'est ok pour qu'on soit sûr
de ne pas avoir de sanction c'est un
jour triste mais au moins on aurait
fermé la loi travail la chance et une
demande effectivement la toile mais au
moins on aurait eu le débat là où se
situer deuxième problème ça n'a jamais
été dit par le président de la
république pendant la campagne
électorale
s'ils prouvent que la vème république ne
fonctionne plus et qu'il faut la changer
le troisième élément c'est que le parti
socialiste y est aujourd'hui au pouvoir
s'est toujours prononcé contre ce type
de réforme
moi j'ai les textes si vous voulez et le
quatrième sujet c'est le 49-3 où on
laisse même pas débattre les députés au
début le 49-3 à la fin à la limite du
débat on peut penser qu'il peut être
légitime et là dès le début on dit il
n'ya pas de débat c'est comme ça et pas
autrement
alors après les gages de raffineries et
les blocages il ya des blocages c'est
grave parce que je pense que la france a
toujours la crainte d'assumer réellement
la démocratie on a toujours là qu'en
deuxième on va retrouver la quatrième
république ou la troisième république
son instabilité et on se dit pas quand
j'ai réhabilité c'est quoi c'est enfin
fonctionnement quand il faut accepter
aujourd'hui que et banias parlement qui
joue tout son rôle puis peut s'opposer
que ça discute que ça négocie que ça
passe des compromis il faut inventer une
démocratie moderne et de ce point de vue
là il faut penser que les gens
aujourd'hui ou aussi un rôle à jouer
les citoyens sont beaucoup plus éduqués
qu'auparavant et beaucoup mieux informés
il faut aussi leur dette
diplômés du supérieur en est d'accord
dominique riquet on n'est pas mature
démocratiquement très mature moi je
constate que dans seulement tu penses
s'exprimer mais à l'intérieur du parti
socialiste un des partis socialistes non
mais donc moi je pense que c'est
effectivement le monde se globalise il
est de plus en plus complexes avec des
gens qui ont vraisemblablement de plus
en plus de formations dont je vous
complexifier forcément la discussion et
ses formes d'expression c'est ce qui se
passe n'a pas peut-être encore un niveau
d'organisation suffisant sir la
démocratie représentative d'avant c'est
peut-être trop simple trop beau ce que
vous disiez sur les corps intermédiaires
voilà dans les corps intermédiaires sont
plus non plus adapté au revoir je pense
qu'il ya une idée
adaptation du brent radical je voudrais
le gouvernement travaille à un clash et
des regards des intervalles quand vous
voyez ce problème en fait de débat
public en france ces blocages et vous le
disiez il y en a en espagne cette
volonté qui est porté par guillaume
balas d'inventer un autre système qui
fonctionnerait sur une forme de
compromis en fait plus large on voit à
quel point par exemple en espagne
actuellement cette capacité en fait de
débat est bloqué il ya toujours pas de
gouvernement est ce que vous diriez que
pour la france c'est peut-être une bonne
solution d'aller vers un fonctionnement
en coalition
je ne veux pas rentrer dans la politique
française
on l'a acheté des problèmes dans la
politique espagnole je me permet pas de
donner des conseils dans la politique
française en tout cas en espagne ce
qu'on a essayé le parti socialiste a
essayé avec tous les moyens c'est de
trouver un accord avec un parti libéral
est un parti de gauche aussi pour
essayer d'avoir une majorité au
gouvernement et pour essayer d'enlever
mariano rajoy du gouvernement
malheureusement le parti de gauche pour
des marchés n'a pas volu trouvé cet
accord et nous devons refaire des
élections le 26 juin pour la première
fois en espagne les élections mais
justement il est regardé la za bel la
transition est toute trouvée je vous
propose un petit détour par l'espagne il
y a un an podemos prenez la tête dans le
cadre d'une coalition avec le parti
socialiste de la mairie de barcelone à
sa tête à dakola haut
nous avons voulu en fait retournés voir
sur place qu'elle était le bilan de ce
mouvement des indignés aujourd'hui à la
tête de l'amm
c'est un reportage de sa mine à déchire
aurélie chamerois et aurélien palier
colinot
ya cinq ans les grandes places d'espagne
ont vu naître la révolte des indignés
aujourd'hui celle de la catalogne à
barcelone est de nouveau investi par les
touristes
le mouvement a créé son parti podemos et
occupe désormais un autre lieu la mairie
l'an dernier à dakola au a été élu maire
de la ville à la tête d'une coalition de
gauche incluant podemos de la rue à la
mairie comment les indignés résiste-t-il
à l'épreuve du pouvoir dans le quartier
populaire de s'entendre et où au milieu
des friches industrielles l'école fils
adorent à la mairie a convié la presse
objectif la présentation d'un plan pour
l'emploi
anin est l'une des bénéficiaires
devraient - ryan gosling restera j'ai
travaillé neuf ans dans un restaurant
quand le gérant est parti à la retraite
je suis allé pointer au chômage
mépris alpes alain alain tourneux paix à
la côte est et reste alors j'ai cherché
du travail je suis allé dans des
associations
jusqu'à ce que j'ai cette opportunité
avec la mairie de barcelone
areva pour la réinsertion des chômeurs
longue durée comme un nain la mairie a
débloqué plus de 17 millions d'euros sur
deux ans et ce thème par la danse mais
comme drame il comptera au total cela
représente approximativement 2 % du
total des chômeurs de la ville c'est une
opération sans précédent
on a mobilisé des ressources municipales
pour pouvoir aider autant de chômeurs
dans l'âme est moche municipal c'est
vraiment un effort sans précédent et
nous pensons que cela donne de bons
résultats tola à la ciotat une opération
communication bien rodée mais à quelques
mètres de l'école nous tombons sur ce
squat menacé d'expulsion par la mairie
le logement c'était pourtant la grande
promesse de la nouvelle équipe
pour en savoir plus nous nous sommes
rendus à une réunion de l'association
qui vient en aide aux victimes de crédit
immobilier
avec les mains quand on est d'accord
caisse coiffer et pendant l'heure quand
on n'est pas d'accord et si il salue la
mise en place d'une unité municipale
chargée de suivre les procédures
d'expulsion sont présents pendant les
expulsions de manière préventive et
réactive ou privilégient l'accès au
logement public
il mobilise des logements vides ils ont
avancé dans ce sens mais très peu denses
en date reste encore beaucoup à faire
plus de 600 procédure aurait été freinée
et 2000 nouveaux logements sociaux sont
promis mais le rythme est lent car la
nouvelle majorité n'a pas toutes les
cartes en main il faut prendre en compte
le fait qu'il gouverne en minorité donc
ils doivent faire des alliances avec
d'autres groupes municipaux ont en effet
pas leur rôle autant ça va finir par les
dégâts d'autres formations politiques et
ils ne peuvent pas faire plus car ils
sont soumis au bon vouloir des autres
autres projets tant la relève un an
après les élections municipales
il est encore trop tôt pour dresser un
bilan les promesses étaient nombreuses
mais à barcelone la coalition au pouvoir
n'a pas assez de voix pour faire adopter
ses réformes
elle a donc dû s'allier aux socialistes
un choix bien différent de la direction
nationale de pau demos à la section
locale du parti
on prépare la campagne des prochaines
législatives
il faudra vérifier dans toutes les
communes que tout le monde a tout le
matériel électoral qu'il lui faut pour
que ce soit bien répartis
après le scrutin de décembre pablo
iglesias le leader de podemos a refusé
de former un gouvernement avec le parti
socialiste
résultat les espagnols sont de nouveau
appelés aux urnes le 26 juin
un pari risqué qui a provoqué des
dissensions dans le parti ata par les
politiques nous en avons eu comme sur
toutes les questions politiques du parti
surtout sur les questions les plus
importantes la mort ap le demos a décidé
de ne pas s'allier avec les socialistes
au final sur la base d'une question
citoyens on a des mots ont été consultés
et ont dit qu'elles n'étaient pas
d'accord la stratégie pourrait s'avérer
payante podemos vient d'annoncer une
alliance avec les néo-communistes
disquaires d'aomi d'un pour les
prochaines législatives
aulas michael il y avait là un intérêt
pour les manches et la majorité des gens
de podemos et des jambes gauche ont
réclamé cette alliance il aurait dû le
faire en décembre donc oui il va doivent
être rapprochés diop est encore là voilà
coach et je pense que c'est une bonne
chose si ces deux parties arrivent à
s'entendre parce que la gauche c'est
toujours pareil on dit tous ensemble et
après on ne s'entend pas été à mon stock
et à manger
je vais continuer à voter podemos je
veux leur donner l'opportunité de
pouvoir gouverner ce pays
c est ce qu ont été aussi elle est
risquée rdda unida je serai en catalogne
podemos reste populaire
il faut dire qu'une partie de
l'électorat indépendantiste a été
séduite par la promesse d'un référendum
d'autodétermination
mais surtout avant de tirer un bilan ces
électeurs veulent laisser aux jeunes
partis le temps de faire ses preuves
retour à bruxelles hayder guardian à
bâle robial vous diriez que podemos
c'est un concurrent ou un allié du parti
socialiste en espagne mais pour
l'instant il était en concurrence
j'espère que plus tard à partir du 26
juin il sera un allié parce que ce dont
nous avons besoin nous avons besoin
d'eux dans l'accord des partis de gauche
pour trouver un gouvernement elle ne put
être sans gouvernement il ya beaucoup de
problèmes en espagne ne peut pas perdre
le temps alors le problème c'est que il
s'avère que si podemos c'est arrivé avec
d'aussi bons scores on est face à
maintenant vous avez quasi quatre
parties en fait sur la scène pour créer
en fait des coalitions
est ce à dire que à l'image de la france
et de françois hollande est typiquement
vous avez aussi failli être en
adéquation en fait avec ce
qu'attendaient tous les électeurs je ne
crois pas le problème ce qu' il ya eu 1
ouvre un nouvel espace qui s'est ouvert
en espagne avec de nouveaux partis
c'étaient les premières élections
générales où il y avait c'est de nouveau
parti est bon maintenant on va voir le
plus grand problème c'est qu'avec quatre
partis qui se présentent aux élections
il y en a bien d'autres évidemment mais
les plus les plus grands c'est quatre
parties ça va être impossible d'avoir un
parti et qui est la majorité absolue
donc forcément il doit y avoir des
désaccords
je ne vois pas trop pourquoi on devrait
aller là de nouvelles élections si les
accords auraient pu se faire avant
hambach cela on a démontré que c'est
possible que nous avons un programme
clairement voisin et allié au parti
socialiste mais là le parti socialiste
c'est celui qui a dû faire un site se
bat en avant et dire on vous donne nos
voix parce qu'on veut vraiment changer
les politiques et se font à barcelone ça
n'a pas été le cas à madrid pour
démasquer c'était à lui de faire ce pas
en avant et ils ont pas voulu
dominique riquet quand on voit que les
indignés espagnols ont créé un parti
podemos qui est aujourd'hui quasi la
quatrième force politique en espagne et
c'est à dire que les partis politiques
traditionnels que l'on connaît auxquels
vous participez sont aujourd'hui un peu
un peu mort demos est un parti très
traditionnel allez on vient de voir
toute histoire de l'organisation pirate
ces gisements importants
oui tout à fait traditionnelle mais en
démocratie
des mouvements de masse plutôt en europe
du sud manifestation de ce type
lorsqu'ils s'organise dans la partie
traditionnelle podemos est devenu mais
alors l'exemple archi typique un parti
politique avec ses permanents sur
matériel électoral la démocratie
participative
lorsqu'elles passent en phase
opérationnelle a pour l'instant pas
trouvé grand chose de mieux que la
démocratie représentative
moi je suis député c'est vrai alors je
trouve ça normal si vous regardez bien
dans le monde va le choix entre parce
qu'il faut redire une chose on est tous
dans des régimes démocratiques
n'enverrait pas les gens discuter à
pyongyang sur les places publiques comme
on est en démocratie des droits de
l'homme sont préservés les gens peuvent
manifester et le régime grenat général
avec ces mouvances vont pas si mal quand
même
oui je suis d'accord c'est là que je
pense qu'à la fois il faut qu'une
articulation entre la société et la
démocratie représentative et là les
partis traditionnels ont à faire un
effort sur la manière d'intégrer
aujourd'hui justement cette conscience
politique à mon avis plus élevé parce
que le niveau d'éducation a augmenté et
que ça il faut il faut en tenir compte
et qui est en construction
voilà et en même temps il n'ya pas de
miracle c'est à dire que moi je ne crois
pas qu'on va passer demain la démocratie
numérique où il n'y a plus de corps
intermédiaires et cetera je pense même
que c'est dangereux parce que pour le
coup il pourrait y avoir une nouvelle
forme de populisme qui surf sur un
individualisme complet politique et où
finalement sans corps intermédiaires ça
permette à certains leaders de faire à
peu près ce qu'ils veulent en s'appuyant
sur plébiscite en fait ça sera du
napoléon iii revisité aujourd'hui 2 0
donc il faudrait des référendums permet
exactement donc il faut faire attention
à l' équilibre entre cette aspiration de
participation et de co-construction
qu'il faut prendre en compte si on
n'apprend pas en compte alors je pense
qu'on va au devant de graves problèmes
et en même temps ne surtout pas souhaité
la disparition des corps intermédiaires
qui sont absolument essentielles
je vais faire une remarque c'est que
bien entendu il ya des mouvements de
base comme du vidéo bout pour der sar
mais massivement le corps électoral il
est en train de migrer vers un système
qui va plutôt vers un système
autoritaire l'extrême droite
s'il faut pas se tromper bon les
journalistes sont beaucoup intéressés
par la place de la république etc
mais c'est ça représente numériquement à
rien du tout effectivement ça fait de
vous mais quand on voit que podemos
syriza en grèce beppe grillo on est allé
il ya des mouvements qui sont comme ça
series en grèce on est passé de
l'extrême gauche h sait pas encore très
bien quoi ravir des plutôt à droite déjà
bon mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
si vous regardez l'ensemble du mouvement
dans les consultations démocratiques
c'est pas du tout ça qui est en train
d'émerger ça ça m'inquiète plus ce que
vous voyez c'est que les gens sont en
train de migrer vers des systèmes
autoritaires
alors certes une petite minorité qui
parle de démocratie participative et
c'est très bien parce que ça fait ça
anime la vie démocratique mais les
électeurs c'est ce qui compte en
démocratie
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas du tout
vers ça je tends vers des formes de
populisme
oui oui mais pas seulement sur des
formes de populisme main sur des formes
d'extrême droite jeu mais c'est très
très dangereux tout à l'heure il faisait
parler de ce qui est arrivé en autriche
mais j'ai pas seulement là dans beaucoup
de pays
en france vous avez le front national
qui a des scores de 20% de l'électorat
c'est très dangereux c'est maintenant
c'est vrai et là y'a même un certain
paradoxe parce que on a l'impression que
les gens ils vendent plutôt à des
mouvements assemblée sur la place pas du
tout pas du tout
ils regardent de plus en plus destrem
droite ce sont des mouvements tout à
fait autoritaire et je pense que c'est
parce que les gens ils ont ils ne voient
pas un futur et non plus d'espoir ou ne
savent plus trop où trouver cet espoir
et ils ont besoin de quelqu'un qui guide
mais avec un bras de fer très très
dangereux de classer ou les partis
politiques il faut qu'on prenne soin de
ceux qui sont en train de passer ça veut
dire guillaume velez ce qu'on est dans
une forme de fracture et on lève
par exemple en autriche avec un candidat
écologiste est en phase en fait un
candidat de droite
tout à l'heure vous disiez que 40% de la
population aujourd'hui est diplômé de
l'enseignement supérieur c'est à dire
qu'il n'y ait encore 60% qui ne l'est
pas et pourtant je crois c'est ce que je
disais au début de l'émission que des
deux côtés on cherche la même chose mais
par des voies totalement différente
c'est à dire que en gros les gens qui
sont les plus diplômés veulent
participer à la vie politique et ne
supporte plus que des élus leur donne
des injonctions s'en expliquer c'est
tous les mouvements qu'on peut voir là
et dans les milieux plus populaires
moins éduqué il ya la recherche de la
protection du chef de celui là va donner
de la sécurité mondiale et dont les deux
voilà et dans les deux cas une recherche
de la souveraineté aux recherches de la
protection on recherche la possibilité
du politique à agir
donc c'est à nous de prouver que la
démocratie est supérieur en termes de
délibérations et d'efficacité par
rapport à l'autoritarisme qui vient et
on est confiant pour sa dominique riquet
je partage la fin mais pas celle d'eric
raffin c'est à dire que l'on est tous
les deux je pense qu'il est roi confiant
dans un système démocratique et qu' on
n'est pas pour des systèmes autoritaires
sûrement pas bon roland je pense que la
dichotomie entre le système autoritaire
chez les gens moins éduqués et le
système démocratique chez jean près du
quai j'y crois pas du tout en un en
autriche et ce qui s'est passé cette
année alors certains récents des
ouvriers quand même qu'on votait pour
organiser la mère d'amélie score
historique pour ce candidat écologiste
qui n'était quelques logist dans les
villes notamment éduqué avec un terne
troadec a remarqué dans mes remarques
le candidat écologiste celle où ils
seraient classés centriste il serait à
ma place non il n'est pas du tout
écologiste la manière dont l'étude est
compétitif mais pas sur le même marché
président lorsque je voulais dire c'est
que là par exemple cette explication
dichotomie entre les gens qui des gens
dont c'est ça que les gens veulent plus
entendre et c'est ça qui peuvent pas
supporter je crois que le monde est
devenu complexe il ya des gens diplômés
bon moi je veux bien quel type de
diplôme meilleur parce que je pense
qu'un diplôme de plombier c'est parfois
aussi formateur qu'à diplôme
universitaire sans emploi bon ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'à société devenue
complexe à réflexion et complexe que
très précisément ce genre de séparation
ne fonctionne pas le problème
c'est que cette scission entre la
société en deux parts fait que la
démocratie directe et participative ne
doit pas être un désordre
sinon elle va entraîner une réaction via
les réactionnaires et ces réactionnaires
ils risquent d'être plus nombreux
et là on a vu ça s'est arrangé eh bien
écoutez on continuera de suivre un ce
qui se passera merci à vous de nous
avoir éclairé sur ces situations
bien entendu vous pouvez réagir chers
téléspectateurs sur notre hashtag europe
hebdo sur les réseaux sociaux la semaine
prochaine vous retrouvez ahmed tazir
bonne semaine à tous